hey guys and welcome back to box look
the project where I simon vlog about my
life in Oxford University every week
along with my friend Jaime he was a
model in college whose channel is in the
doobly-doo
what this week has been completely
focused on my Master's projects like
last week I didn't actually have a
problem shoot you in this Friday which
is the blessing so I could just dedicate
myself to spending day after day in the
lab which is now finally reached
fruition it's got to the point where all
the computer code which I've written for
my Master's project actually does its
job doesn't properly it's been
rigorously tested and I'll all I have to
do is plug in the regions I'm interested
in give us some parameters press ENTER
and walk away so what's left to do now
is look at the results which I've got
from my camp these programs plot a few
things which come from various different
graphs together draw some conclusions
and write it up unfortunately I still
have to do that that's actually how this
projects being assessed it's very large
part of my degree so I have to do it
properly also in kind of physics II kind
of social news I had the privilege of
being able to go to a talk poster by the
physics society which was locked by Mike
talking about string theory now because
I'm a member of the committee of the
physics society I actually got to have
dinner with a professor beforehand and
frankly I am still puzzling now days
later he's a theoretical physicist who
actually majored in American University
in maths and music and is just not what
you'd expect theoretical physicist to be
like at all he was funny charming
extremely personable and it's now nice
that I'm at the point in my physics
understanding where I could actually
have a talk with him about some of the
quantitative aspects of string theory
and know why it is a thing and how it
does and specifically how it sort of
differs from quantum field theory if you
want to see any of Brian work stuff he's
actually part of a company I'm saying
this a comedy duo called ninja sex party
who got over five million views on
YouTube and he's also involved in a
science storytelling show which is also
a podcast called the story Collider so
in more legitimately social stuff I
haven't actually be doing all that much
history because my Master's project
because I've started getting back into
going to the gym after I had a little
bit very went off the rails on
again now but on Saturday I was part of
open day here at San Peters I was
helping out this tuna helper I'm getting
show people around a common theme which
arose and actually something which I've
noticed on the internet and from the Kim
from you guys to watch my videos is
concern over whether there's a social
scene Oxford whether if you want to go
out you can't and whether it's
essentially whether it's boring so in
order to investigate the situation I
went to a house party on Saturday night
my friend's house down in Cali Road and
from there on to the o2 Academy where on
Saturday nights its propaganda now I
must admit I'm not much for clubbing
person myself but so you know this is
how dedicated an guys like this I forget
some footage to the other side of a real
actual club
so a propaganda is like an indie rock
night and at the o2 in Oxford last night
they have the enemy flame ultimate I
didn't really know that much about their
music but the DJ say afterwards was
really fun
and it's kind of representative right so
there's loads of clubs in the centre of
Oxford ETS which is almost like an
extension of the Peters che sia after
bops that's just where everybody goes
you also have bridge junction park end
number 9 if you're being adventurous
it's an advantage of being a Central
College so if you do want to go out you
can walk within about two minutes from
some Peters to about four different
clubs which is handy if it's very cold
so Jamie he wants me what I wanted to be
when I was a kid like you actually I
wants to be an astronaut but that was
the for the longest time before that the
earliest thing which I can remember
wanting to be was a paleontologist I
think I saw Jurassic Park I'm walking
with dinosaurs and I just in my head it
was just like everything I could have
ever want it so even even now I still
know I can walk around the National
History Museum it should be like that's
Paris Wallace's that's a Stegosaurus
that's a gif cephalus it have so much
useless stuff that my brain them those
are the out my degree at all and my
question to you kind of is a logical
continuation I guess what did you do for
your work experience and do you think
that it has any relevance at all to
applying to universities now my question
to you guys the audience so we've
strayed from the purpose of what this
project was a little bit we were talking
about video games and and some other
kind of stuff like that so let's get
back to purpose now I want everybody to
participate in this one cuz I think this
is a really important question so it's
your first interview you've just sat
and your tutor looks across at you and
says so why did you choose to do this
subject what do you say now all probably
do is in the next video I'd like to go
through everybody's responses and pick
out the kind of trends that you guys
have picked up on and maybe suggest a
few things if you like this video then
please do give it a like it lets me know
what you guys find useful and find
entertaining of course if you don't then
don't
you should have standards and I will see
you guys next Sunday Jamie I look
forward to seeing you on Thursday